well i want to thank john for allowing
us to do this thank you john my pleasure
thank you thank you for co-hosting this
with me i appreciate it the place is
even prettier and more beautiful than
you described in city seriously it's
magical this is special so you own all
this
three acres oh so beautiful
yeah i would never leave here ever
no children never been married living on
an island i mean i think you are the
epitome of what men
wish they would have done
so what is the right woman for you like
what's your type what are you looking
for what's the right woman i don't know
that i'm
looking for anything because i'm happy
with that but i mean i love i love it
would you like to intelligent
intelligence uh you know beauty fades
but you know so luanne
is very intelligent
and uh
obviously she's very funny
so do you have a physical type
oh poor johnny don't put him on the spot
he's alright
well let's see
let's do this does he like blondes or
brunettes
yeah i feel bad for him on it because i
know she likes john but see this is the
thing you can't keep poking the bear
because when you poke the bear
you never know how the bear's gonna
react
ramona went for kenya a lot of times
called their [ __ ] and you know [ __ ] you
and
and now kenya's like [ __ ] you
i spent some time with you guys and you
know a couple and i was expecting a
little more drama and you guys all seem
to like each other and it's really
refreshing and nice no i mean it's nice
i mean you're saying like i'm ramona you
weren't paying attention
[Music]
at the beginning of the trip you should
have seen what happened on the yacht the
other day
what happened on the other day
[Music]
ramona tried to blackmail
[Music]
it's almost like when you're at like
dinner with your children and you're
grinding your teeth and you're like you
better behave ramona was like girls
we're gonna behave nicely we're at my
friend's house and then kenny's like
yeah no we're actually not i got cursed
dead and then you know
she told me to cook off
and then there was crying and running
around and it was like oh my god okay
well she was
looking like she was crying but there
were actually no tears coming out of her
eyes
wow yeah it was an interesting and i
love you too can you yeah it's a lot
cheers to kenny i don't think you do
yeah i i'm just kind of kind of cause
you said you
to me and [ __ ] off
[Music]
do you really think this is the right
time i played yeah it was that was that
much trouble yeah we were talking about
things that happened at a beautiful
man's dinner i'm hosting it you're
having a great time right john
yeah but i want everyone to be happy too
right
[Applause]
i'm actually embarrassed because john
and our other guests do not need to hear
this this is not proper dinner
conversation
and this is really low even for kenya
i'm just playing with everybody and
luanne right now is just a little
bystander not saying hey can you stop
not good conversation miss manners miss
etiquette
please
[Music]
and give ramona a little rise
that's what i'm looking for
giving her the medicine she probably
needs
oh i have my opportunity yes do it
this situation reminds me of that movie
carlito's way
oh pretty that's so beautiful remember
he's trying to escape he's trying to get
on the train with the love of his life
and the guy calls his name and said
remember me and then shoots him right
there oh we're gonna have to do some
s'mores john yes we are do you have any
marshmallows too
kenya has benny blanco chocolate
marshmallow crackers
ramona's not gonna make it out of this
dinner with the love of her life the way
it's going i can't handle this part
she's running right in on her man
are you from
toronto right yeah
awesome
i used to take my hoops off like
that woman
feel it can you feel it